et puis tout de suite vu de Russie Elena
polochine qui va revenir qui analyse la
propagande de Vladimir Poutine sur fond
de guerre en Ukraine et désormais sur
fond de guerre au Proche Orient bonsoir
Elena bonsoir Stéphanie le regard de
Moscou bien sûr sur cette guerre on le
suit évidemment et on va suivre cet
échange de là-bas aussi cet échange dont
on a beaucoup parlé ce soir entre otage
israélien et prisonniers palestiniens
oui alors ça ne fait pas autant la une
de l'actualité que chez nous mais depuis
Moscou mais on a suivi plutôt la
conférence sur l'intelligence
artificielle aujourd'hui à laquelle a
participé Vladimir Poutine et où il a
déclaré que la Russie devait développer
sa propre intelligence artificielle
fondée sur les valeurs traditionnelle
face à une intelligence artificielle
occidentale qui a qualifié de russophobe
des mots et des concepts que la Russie
applique donc à tous les domaines depuis
qu'elle est en guerre ouverte avec
l'Ukraine mais la chaîne d'information
continue russi à 24 a quand même eu ce
qu'on appelle dans notre jargon cette
brève
regardez nous venons d'apprendre qu'un
premier groupe de 1 otages israéliens
qui ét détenu dans la bande de Gaza a
été transmis aux employés de la Croix
Rouge Internationale c'est ce qu'annonce
times of Israël citant une source
israélienne l'Égypte annonce également
que 12 citoyens Thaïlandais ont été
libérés nous continuons de suivre la
situation et vous communiquerons tous
les détails et fond de cette guerre au
proch Orient Vladimir Poutine tire son
épingle du jeu oui d'abord parce que la
guerre au Proche-Orient a détourné
l'attention de la communauté
internationale bien sûr du dossier
ukrainien et alors que le monde a les
yeux rivés sur Gaza Poutine il cherche
plus que jamais à recréer ces taxe des
pays non alignés conduits par Moscou
pour se poser en médiateur dans ce
conflit cette semaine alors qu'il était
convié mercredi à participer à un sommet
virtuel du G20 organisé par l'Inde la
veille il a organisé ce qu'on pourrait
appeler un contre somommet virtuel des
bricks Brésil Russie Inde Chine Afrique
du Sud groupe qui s'élargira en janvier
prochain à l'Arabie Saoudite l'Égypte
les Émirats arabes unis l'Iran
l'Éthiopie et l'Argentine alors au
sommet de ce sommet virtuel il y avait
bien sûr le conflit au Proche-Orient et
des appels de tous les participants au
cess le feu à Gaza écoutez d'abord le
compte-rendu qu'en a fait le journal
télévisé de P canal c'est la première
chaîne de télévision russe qui suit il
faut le repréciser toujours à la lettre
la ligne imposée par le krémelin
regardez la catastrophe humanitaire ne
peut être arrêtée que par des actions
urgentes et concertées les conséquences
du blocus des civils sont terrifiantes
des petits enfants sont
sur les chqu géopolitiques on essaie de
les soigner dans des hôpitaux privés
d'électricité c'est terrible et lorsque
l'on voit comment on opère des enfants
sans anesthésie cela provoque des
sentiments
particuliers alors le lendemain au
sommet virtuel du G20 donc Vladimir
Poutine il a réitéré ces mêmes propos
mais cette fois il a aussi répété les
mythes fondateurs de son agression
contre l'Ukraine tout ceci pour dresser
un parallèle avec la guerre au proche-
Orient alors que pour la première fois
depuis son attaque de l'raine il avait
une plateforme directe pour s'adresser
au chef d'État et au Diplomat de aur
occidentaux qui condamne sa guerre
regardez lors de leurs allocutions
certains collègues se sont dit choqués
par la poursuite de l'agression russe en
Ukraine et le fait que des médecins
doivent opérer en découpant la chair des
enfants au scalpel sans
anesthésie ch
pas que le Secrétaire général de
l'Organisation des Nations Unies disent
que Gaza est un cimetière d'enfants
géants ça ça ne vous choque
pas que ce G0 a été boudé par Joe Biden
etjining oui sauf quejining était bien
présent la veille lors du sommet virtuel
des bricks donc que nous avons évoqué
organisé par Moscou et là tout tout
comme Vladimir Poutine il a appelé un c
le feu immédiat à Gaza de leur côté les
présidents iraniens et sud-africains ont
employé le mot génocide pour qualifier
cette guerre menée par Israël à Gaza
Vladimir Poutine clairement il vise le
temps d'après l'échange d'otage et de
prisonniers dont nous parlons tous
aujourd'hui le but de ce sommet des
bricks tout comme de la réunion qui
s'est tenu il faut le souligner le même
jour à Moscou c'est-à-dire mardi entre
le ministre des Affaires étrangères
russes Sergey Lavrov et ses homologues
de la Ligue arabe et de l'organisation
de la coopération islamique ce but était
bien de replacer les pays arabes l'Iran
et Moscou au centre de ce dossier et de
condamner une fois de plus l'hégémonie
américaine écoutez cet autre extrait du
journal télévisé
russe cela fait maintenant plusieurs
décennies que l'autorité de
l'Organisation des Nations Unies ne
suffit plus pour forcer Washington à
renoncer à son statut de mentor
autoproclamé qui bloque la création d'un
État palestinien souverain le nouveau
centre de gravité formé par les C pays
des BRI et les nouveaux membres de cette
formation qui va s'élargir en janvier
2024 est un nouveau levier géopolitique
dans un monde multipolaire en
formation tous ces événements sont une
conséquence directe des efforts des
États-Unis pour monopoliser les fonction
de médiateur dans le processus de paix
israëlo-palestinien et pourant sont bien
les États-Unis avec le Qatar qui ont
mené négociation pour libérer les otages
Israéliens et les prisonniers
palestiniens oui les muss mentionne pas
et là-dessus d'ailleurs la Russie elle
s'aligne sur la rhétorique du Hamas les
médias russes ils disent que c'est le
Qatar et l'Égypte qui auraiit mener les
négociations même si l'Égypte a joué un
rôle important mais un rôle logistique
alors que les États-Unis ont négocié au
côté du Qatar
écoutez l'accord a été atteint grâce à
la médiation du Qatar et de l'Égypte il
porte sur un échange d'otage et de
prisonniers et la livraison d'aide
humanitaire à Gaza la négociation a pu
aboutir grâce aux efforts des médiateurs
cataris et égyptiens
un représentant du Hamas a déclaré que
ses efforts ne dataient pas d'hier les
pourparl ont duré un mois grâce à la
médiation de l'Égypte et du Qatar nous
les remercions pour cela nous espérons
que l'agression va cesser et que notre
peuple pourra souffler avec soulagement
conformément au cesser le feu les civils
seront échanger contre des femmes et des
enfants que les occupants retiennent
dans leur
prison et de son côté le Joe Biden a
publié samedi dernier une tribune dans
le Washington Post où il appelle lui
aussi à une solution impérative et
immédiate à deux états oui il exclut
aussi la déportation des Palestiniens de
Gaza sa réoccupation son siège et son
blocus par Israël ainsi qu'une réduction
de la taille des territoires palestinien
mais dans le même temps il dit qu'il ne
peut pas y avoir de cesser le feu tant
que le Hamas n'a pas été éradiqué mais
tout cela non plus c'est détails les
médias russe ne les donne pas en
revanche le présentateur vedette de la
télévision russe Vladimir soloviov il a
moqué ouvertement le président américain
Joe Biden en s'appuyant sur l'ancien
président désormais de nouveau candidat
à l'investiture répu à l'élection
présidentielle Donald Trump
regardez mêmeon se doute que Biden est
incapable d'écrire un quelconque article
qu'est-ce qu'il irit écrire alors qu'il
est incapable de lire ce qu'il n'a même
pas écrit Trump d'ailleurs a des mots
assez durs pour
Biden notre dirigeant est
stupide dirigeant est incapable de
quitter une scène vous avez
vu quand il a fini de parler qu'il faut
partir il est
là
merci
merci par où est-ce que je
[Applaudissements]
m'vis c'est vrai que ça se rapoche de la
véritéque de lait présé Joe Biden mais
avec l'élection présidentielle l'année
prochaine aux États-Unis tout cela n'est
pas àodin que faut-il en retenir et bien
d'abord que l'Ukraine est en grande
difficulté parce qu'il n'y a pas de
percée significative sur le front et que
Joe Biden lui-même est en difficulté
pour faire voter une nouvelle tranche
d'aide financière au Congrès l'aide
militaire elle les Ukrainiens la
considèrent déjà insuffisante pour leur
permettre d'obtenir des avancées
significative quant à Vladimir Poutine
lui que l'on disait totalement isolé sur
la scène internationale et bien qu'il
soit on le rappelle sous le coup d'un
mandat d'arrêt de la Cour pénale
internationale il entend bien tirer
profit du dossier proche- oriental on le
voit d'ailleurs très prudent et très
mesuré dans ses propos ce n'est pas du
tout le cas de son allié iranien mais
précisément Vladimir Poutine il ménage
les deux camps parce qu'il entend bien
supplanter les États-Unis dans le rôle
du
négociateur merci Elena vue de Russie